can you talk about the five years you
put in trying to get people to invest in
your first movie
it was a long journey
but
well worth it
um
I would say that initially
when I when I when I first started
to go after
different people to try to see if you
know I didn't have the money to make a
movie right so I mean what I had was a
script and I just had the passion for
actually doing it right to actually want
to do it rather
and um
uh what happened was you know I went
around to a bunch of people you know
probably I don't know
10 people just over the course of
you know maybe a few years
in action you know people that I felt
like okay well maybe I can get it from
him maybe I can get it from her or
whatever but again
um
it was it was I think that
you know the the challenge for me was
the fact that
um and probably the reason why a lot of
people didn't want to invest was because
I didn't I didn't have a sound
um business idea
so you know at that point it was just a
passion project right it was okay well I
want to make this movie but I didn't
even have any data to tell people okay
well this is how much meat we can make
off of this because I didn't know right
and I'm sure most beginning filmmakers
people who have scripts and they looking
to get into this how would you have any
data there's no data available you don't
know so
that was a that right there was a
challenging moment for me and eventually
what I end up telling myself was
I'm not going to keep action people to
give me no money because I came to that
conclusion
and I said
you know this is not going to happen
because number one I can't even show
people how they gonna make their money
back right number two which is which is
let me go back which is very different
now what all these streaming services
out here if a newer filmmaker is trying
to get someone to invest in a project
and I'm talking uh independent project
where your budget might be
let's say 50 to 70 000 right
you know the best thing you can do is go
find a producer who can help you
show some numbers
I didn't have that available to me right
so
throughout that process I think I
probably spent about three years
trying to get somebody to give me money
right I thought I needed
um 20 000 25 000 so I'm trying to get
this money
yeah it didn't happen ultimately it
didn't happen and and I think that it
didn't happen because it wasn't supposed
to happen so now that I think back on it
right we're gonna go back to that whole
rejection thing again
so I think that there I was being
rejected because it wasn't time
and ultimately what ended up happening
was I ended up coming up with the money
myself
and when I find and and when I when I
came up with the uh with the with the
funding for the project
um you know that kept me in position
where I could retain
100 ownership
to my content right and by that time I
had more information
and
another good thing was the fact that
if I have made that investment with
somebody else's money I would have had
to figure out like how do I hurry up and
get that money back but by being my
money
I was able to be patient and just work
the process through because even when I
Shot the movie My First Movie it took me
like a year and a half to get
distribution
because I didn't I didn't know I didn't
know any of this so all of this was new
to me so imagine me getting twenty five
thousand dollars forty thousand dollars
whatever from somebody to shoot a movie
and it's sitting I'm sitting on it for a
year and a half right imagine the kind
of pressure that would have been so when
I say that I just mean that
um
that all of these all these things
happen
in my situation and it could be
different for somebody else I feel like
in my situation it happened the way that
it was supposed to
and
um
and it was it was it was a long process
but I eventually got it done
and I did it on my time and I did it on
I did it the way I wanted to
why wouldn't anyone invest in your first
movie I know you said you were chasing
twenty thousand twenty five thousand was
this from the same person or that was
different people I think I think nobody
wanted to invest in it because as I said
I don't think I had a solid business
plan
not to mention the fact that I had no
experience
and on top of the fact that I was asking
people to invest in a movie that didn't
that knew nothing about the movie
business
right so I think that a lot of investors
who
are going to come on board and invest in
the artist is someone who is have some
level of passion for artistry
and a lot of a lot of the individuals
they just that that wasn't something
that they was interested in
so you know I don't I don't um
I don't hold nothing against anybody I
just think that
you know
um
that once again that's one of those
things where you have to be realistic
and you have to move in a way when
you're seeking out investors and things
like that you need to be dealing with
people who
are real prospects
and at that time I just didn't know
um anybody outside of anybody within the
film industry outside I only knew the
people from that I had knew you know
just in my life in general I didn't I
didn't know anybody in the film industry
personal question here but how much did
of your own money did you put in
to your first movie
um first movie Total probably marketing
plus the movie probably was about forty
thousand dollars
and it was all at once or it was over
the course of a few years well no it was
that was uh that was uh I probably put
more into it I mean if you talk about
you know plane tickets and all that and
all that kind of stuff but initially it
was a it was about the first the initial
budget was I want to say twenty five
thousand dollars
for the movie
and then the marketing of it it was a 15
came later once the film was out and you
know what not
okay
all right that's that's a good chunk
that's
not sure it's doable for everybody but
yeah that's and and so you felt did you
did you feel good too and that you
didn't need to keep chasing these
individuals around like for asking them
checking in with them
yeah it it it it felt
um
it
at the at the time it was so much going
on to where I didn't I wasn't able to
think about it oh I see okay but later
on you know in retrospect you think back
on things you think back on years like
okay after you've built a catalog
and
you start to look at some of the stuff
you've done I mean you can appreciate
that
you did it on your own terms
you know and and
had I not
continue to press
uh forward with one to do the first
movie even with all the rejection that I
was getting had I not continued to push
forward
um
I wouldn't be here right now so
um it's
it's
um
is fulfilling you know now to know that
first of all
um
I was able to accomplish that Milestone
that was a big milestone in my life and
it was also a big milestone
you know just in my career as a producer
you know a lot of people they asked me
would you ever shoot circumstances one
over and I tell them
I probably wouldn't and the reason why
because I think that it's important
for a young filmmakers to see
what you can come from right so and when
I say that I mean that the production
value the hustle
everything that it took to make that
movie right even with all the
imperfections in the movie
I still excuse me I still wouldn't even
with even with all the imperfections in
the movie I still wouldn't want to shoot
it over
because
I think that
to me it's a piece of history that I
wouldn't want to take away from someone
who is at that level right someone who's
at that level
of
of wanting to become a filmmaker they
need to see some realistic work
a realistic
idea of what can happen with
with a what a budget that's not so big
right because most people
um
they can attain a budget of twenty five
thousand dollars they can they can you
know if if if you work hard enough and
you focus you can do that but it's a but
it's a different level when you're
talking about a hundred thousand dollar
movie right the production value is
different so I mean you want a beginning
project like that
to be
um
a starting
um a starting line for somebody who is
trying to break in the industry and they
don't have a lot of resources